he stays in the news cycle all the time
24 hours a day
all around the clock and how calculated
is that for him
like is he waking up the morning going
okay how are we going to affect the news
cycle
it used to be super calculated i think
he's in a rut right now no before before
i'm talking like in your guy's heyday
was it like we wake up in a hotel
and you're like well most of the things
i ended up getting blamed for a lot of
things
like he's he's he could run a news page
like i'm going to tell you how just
methodical and this is where people
don't realize
people it looks organic yeah yeah and it
is organic but a lot of because if you
are natural to him he [ __ ]
understands it he was a cameraman he was
just running he was a cameraman
he edited all his videos till he went to
jail son once
every remember when he got kidnapped he
was editing the video with
nicki minaj son once we told you the
story yeah because he would just
play this imagine being one of the
biggest superstars in the world yeah
and the label is probably like you could
have like you know for like a drake they
were like
the budget for the videos yeah a million
dollars he gave a million
guys playing right for six nine he could
have probably commanded a budget of like
300 thousand right yeah yeah you know
what he would do
just hit his two homies they grab a
camera and probably the props said where
they go they're gonna film in a hood
somewhere right
it'd probably be like twenty thousand
dollars like that if that that's even a
lot
just keep the rest it's not even no i
don't even think he was even thinking
about that i think
he was just asked to label the labels
like wait you only need like
ten thousand dollars okay like this is
the cheapest thing we ever paid for
yeah i think nikki comes to one of the
joints
and i think she was like yo whoa no
she's a queen of course she's like not
by doing your little hood videos get the
[ __ ] out of here
get this production value up and math
fact i need a bunch of jets you know i
mean which is which is dope you know
but he's always had that approach of
it's almost like a youtuber that did
music yeah he used to call me every day
it would be almost like yo i'm posting
at three o'clock
make sure you grab it from my page and
post it yeah repost it right
his thing with three o'clock is that's
kids are out
yeah that's the time throughout the day
yeah it's most active yeah yeah well the
kids find school
yo when people like most of these
rappers who are promoting their [ __ ]
they put up a preview at 3am yeah i
don't even care 3am i'm in the studio
i'm drunk and high [ __ ]
yeah let's you guys check it out he was
careful
and meticulous enough to say hey yeah
how do i
work all this instagram social media
[ __ ] to my event well think about it
think about the time
kids let's say you post something at 12.
the kids can still see it at 12
they can't share with their friends they
can't comment they're trying to hide
their phone in class they're maybe run
to the bathroom to do it
at three that's when you get the
algorithm pumping everybody's out of
school
they're passing all around you want to
be part of this thing that's going viral
you're creating your own content
based on it as well i mean you have that
freedom because you're probably not with
your parents just yet
studying so there's that little gap once
we found out he edited his own [ __ ]
yeah because we're in the [ __ ]
trenches with creating content right
like
so once once we found out he edited his
own [ __ ] it flipped my whole perspective
on him and i was never some of his
anti-ham i was
i was super impressed by the way that he
could like galvanize
people's attention and there's a low
brow way to galvanize which is beef
beef is low brown beef is like you want
to hear a crazy story all right go go go
go
but i want to create a caveat before i
criticize it just like
beef is low brown the same way that like
mafia movies are low lowbrow like it's
easy to get me interested in mafia it's
easy to get me interested in selling
drugs you know
you make a movie about [ __ ] potatoes
and you make it really good
that's impressive you know what i mean
that being said
it's what you do around that and that
[ __ ]
knows content and more most importantly
he knows how people react to content
yo all right ghost crazy so this is in
the midst of the beef
everybody wants to kill him one week
he's be from yg
the next minute he's beefing somebody
else in new york casanova
he's going crazy by the way so
surreal and crazy to me he's living in
brooklyn
like just on the same street that's
crazy yeah it was so anyway
we just kind of moved about you weren't
like i told him i said bro you got to
come to jersey i want to show you higher
limit yeah
like you're getting way too much weight
but for whatever reason that was just
and i don't know um for people who grew
up in a certain environment maybe
that just still feels at home yeah don't
want to like and also you might not even
think that's struggling you know i mean
like
now he's used so much a higher living
but like before he was just like
i'm comfortable like here yeah like even
when he got kidnapped he was across the
street from
from a park and it was like they're
playing basketball all day like how the
[ __ ] do you go in and out of an
apartment building
and it was like a high rise just like
it's like a two family apartment anyway
i kicked it with him one day and like we
went like the mall or something like
that and
he's surrounded by all these gang dudes
and centered and i always respected him
because
while those elements were around he knew
like that's not me
and he always made sure it was like all
right cool y'all chill over there
i'm gonna just go kick away that's how
we build a real relationship
and we're kicking it whatever whatever
and even then like they're they're
following us
to the thing they got all type of cars
he's like nah i'm right back
and we're driving like i i have my car
at this time uh
some convert wasn't there's a coupe
right he brings his backpack whatever
the case is we go to the place and i
remember
we got separated or like he had to go
with them somewhere
and i did he calls me later and said
i have a video dropping tomorrow i need
to edit it i left my backpack
in your [ __ ] car and i'ma be honest
with you
the whole time i'm sweating bullets i'm
gonna tell you why everybody wants to
kill him i'm thinking he'd probably have
all type of legal guns
i don't know what he got in this
backpack yeah but i wonder i'm like yo i
always thought i'm like yo what type of
kid is this because he presents to me a
certain
front and we're cool yeah and he's
always is very organic in it he seems
sincere
but sometimes when i see him beef and
i'm like this guy looked like he either
got a death wish or
he knows something i don't know right
yeah and i'm looking at the bag and i'm
like
should i open this [ __ ] let's
check this out because i'm like
it's no way it's no way he's talking so
crazy yeah
and in this bag he don't got at least
five guns he got to
and i'm like this is early on in a
relationship yeah this is early on
but i'm like yo but everybody wants to
kill them yeah yeah yeah yeah so i'm
like
all right should i oh i'm like yo i feel
like i'm kind of invading this privacy
type of [ __ ] like that
and i'm like yeah i'm gonna come bring
the bag
um early in the morning to wherever you
live at
and i go to the car and i see the bag
and i'm like
nah bro you should just stay out of
whatever you got going on just drive it
and another mine
says ack you ain't kind of cool you need
to know
[ __ ] open the back i open the bag
and when i look at it it's a [ __ ]
hard drive a computer and
like couple sticks of gum that's it
wanted to kill you and you don't have
like he was like super carefree like all
right cool and i'm like you have to have
a bunch of guns in there and i'm
thinking like these guns
i might get pulled over these guys like
these guns my body's on them like
this is the trade way guns oh my god i'm
freaking out
and i opened it i'm like oh it's a
[ __ ]
apple 369 bro
oh and like let him have his [ __ ] back
okay so what did he know what were you
gonna say i just don't think it
it was a full black ball because i think
the fans also
lost faith in him similar what happened
kind of with joe
it's like yo what i'm saying but he put
a message out it's like i'm gangsta
and like to an extent i believed it
because like he was talking that [ __ ] he
had dudes that
were about it and maybe he wasn't doing
it but if you roll with dudes that are
doing it like
you kind of accomplish but the moment he
gets in trouble he sells them out so now
it's like the thing that i
liked you for i no longer believe it and
so it's like
i can't hear the music to say there came
the biggest question because i
used to talk to him in jail and i said
yo you're gonna get out
and the streets ain't gonna [ __ ] with
you and i remember him
saying listen i had my reasons
if they can't accept it it's gonna be
whatever yeah but
i have a completely different audience
that don't give a [ __ ]
about that type of [ __ ] and it's true
like i went to a show
they don't you you think they were
looking at him like he was jesus
like they didn't care who he told on you
know i mean
oh my god like like they look at the
pretty colors they love it and
and and that's where i was saying i
don't think
you might look at it because the
quote-unquote streets turn their back on
him like maybe you won't listen to him
making that type of music oh yeah we
believe it
but there's a whole different audience
that loves it like keep in mind
he dropped an album while being
blackballed and still sold 50 some
thousand
they blackballed tory and respectfully i
love tori tori's not
tory's not selling records they're black
when they hit you with that black ball
and they take off those playlists that's
hard
like to give you the equivalency if the
industry had supported that album
that sold 57 000 who just sold at least
220.
but i mean there was he was using them
but so let's just break that down
that's almost superstar numbers that's
superstar numbers
yeah how do you get how you break that
because about 80
i keep keep saying around 80 of plays
so if he was supported it would be at
least four times the amount here's the
thing
his numbers without it was still strong
enough to
still appear it looked weak because
you're looking at a superstar
but for anyone else it's not going to be
there that's what i'm saying he could
exist
maybe it's not the audience like if you
go into the [ __ ] hood you're probably
going to hear his music
but if you go to like a lot of these
places that have a lot of hispanic
people that i learned a lot about
demographics i went to a lot of shows
that he did
the demographics is wild mexicans love
him they look yo
we performed right near i remember we we
went there and they're like
the reason we have like i'm like did
y'all have like 300 cops because
of six times they're like no the car
tells us
no they're like we just had like there's
a cartel war like not too long ago like
right there i'm like huh
we're probably the wrong place with the
world's most famous steps hold on
anyway
sells out the whole [ __ ] venue all
hispanic kids
yeah a couple whites in there too yeah
not much blacks
but i get to realize i'm like [ __ ] you
could sustain a career or for that
audience
it won't it won't be your conversation
piece yeah but are the numbers real
though cause like there was a little
speculation he was using bots
the numbers got to be really when you
get 7000 people in the arena in hidalgo
texas
that's the other thing it's like tickets
at the end of the day are you selling
tickets
do people leave their crib but yeah
maybe he is uh you know using the bots i
guess the bots were to
inflate the youtube numbers or something
like that
everybody uses both let me put this to
that everybody teach us about boxing
yeah
i need to learn that no you don't want
to use it for like your regular youtube
channel oh okay it's going to [ __ ] up
what you got going on yeah yeah
what i'm talking about is like the music
industry
the music industry has always been let's
make the fans think this is hot and that
they now
like fans radio when they play
a song 20 times a day it's called radio
programming you're programming the mind
of
a stan or like someone who's
impressionable yeah so you need to make
them think
no one wants to support the thing that
no one's [ __ ] with like
but if it's like yo this [ __ ] did 20
million a day yeah
you know kids are going to be like this
is hot yeah and and
every label puts at least at least
10 to 15 and i would i would i would
speculate this is just me
between 10 to 15 to 30. now the ones who
go
wild and get like 70 to 80 it's clear
like you could tell me that you're like
no this is all fake and that's where
they [ __ ] up like who
i mean i think at times i think friends
montana did really really
or his label did it for him so he might
not know but i think social boy did it
one time too
really i don't know if he did again i'm
saying the artist but i don't think
they're doing it
is their labels which song i remember
soldier had a song it had like four
million
four million views and like 40 comments
like it was wild
it was that's when they were buying the
comments too you gotta you gotta do the
whole package
i know someone who does that [ __ ] for
like like for labels and artists i won't
expose what artists are labeled who
and like some of them is just smaller
artists try to seem bigger
and the dude is like yo yo he's like yo
my fingers [ __ ] hurt because i have
to type comments as like
50 different people like you have to
type all those comments
you get me oh [ __ ] and again it's it's
cool
if you're not wilder now but if you see
rapper a with five million views you're
like we've never heard about you
that's right right so usually labels
they gauge it
people think this video should do about
a hundred thousand we're gonna make it
seem hot it's gonna do around 200 000
but we're gonna put extra comments in
there in the same third that's how they
do
you know it's all about manipulating the
audience
and takashi was a master at it but
i'm not saying in terms of that but like
of course like without bots
what understand about people that the
average person doesn't
that's a good question i don't think
it's what he understands about people
oh actually you're right and
he understands i think he understands
about the industry and people okay
people primarily want the [ __ ] they
want the [ __ ] they want the [ __ ]
okay they don't they don't want
this they want to get on instagram and
watch it crash
chaos logical new ones [ __ ] all that
they want
like and that's why i mean i took a
picture that's why
when we started i said listen [ __ ] all
this background question buy a bathroom
let's get straight to the beef yeah